there's a story behind the production of
every piece of art those stories aren't
always interesting but this one is an
adventure in space and time technically
speaking not actually a doctor whose
story proper but definitely one that if
you are a Doctor Who fan I hope you have
seen because it's well worth watching so
in case you don't know what this is is
this is a dramatization of the creation
of Doctor Who in 1963 and of basically
the William Hartnell run on the
character it's written and was exactly
produced by Mark Gatiss who had actually
been trying to get it made
even before dr. who came back so he'd
been at this a while and obviously Mark
Gatiss has also written episodes of
Doctor Who and acted in it so he's
clearly a very big fan and very
passionate about this and so we have all
of the background players and those and
both behind the camera and the prominent
figure obviously of those who were in
front of the camera the primary focus in
this is on Sidney Newman who had the
original creative spark on it Barry
Lambert who was the first producer not
only of this show but was the first
female producer at the BBC
. period Wars Hussein who was the
director of the episodes initially and
of course William Hartnell the first
doctor himself other people are also
show up now I'm not one to talk about
the historical veracity of what is shown
I I'm not gonna say don't care cuz I
kind of do because what does or doesn't
get changed like can show the level of
respect being shown to some people over
others cuz usually almost anybody's
gonna get shafted or failed to recognize
or some people over recognized but the
thing is I'm
not good at that kind of research
because I it's not something that I have
a particular drive to do so if you're
looking for what did they get right what
did they change about what really
happened I don't know my understanding
and what I've seen from other people's
reaction is that this appears to be
pretty accurate to the actual events but
I don't know what was changed I don't
know what was altered I don't know what
was left out I don't know what was made
up so I am gonna be judging this purely
as a piece in its own right not as a
recreation of historical events because
I'm really kind of taking the things
word on it that this was what happened
so it does a really good job of
highlighting the contributions of all of
the people who took part in this
obviously right off the bat we have
Sydney Newman big boisterous takes all
the oxygen out of the room big ideas and
that's basically what he comes up with
the idea of the doctor and he and the
original cast and they traveled through
space and time and it's educational and
he basically just plopped it down in
front of Barry Lambert said I want you
to produce it go make it so like the
initial kernel wouldn't exist without
Sydney Newman but he didn't Shepherd it
it's the core difference between you
know when you see a film there's a story
by credit and then there's a screenplay
by credit if you ever see that there is
a reason that those are sometimes two
different things one person might have
come up with the idea somebody else
actually put pen to paper and move
forward on it not that Verity Lambert
was it was the writer but she was on the
ground working with the writers the
directors getting the thing actually up
and running where as Sydney Newman got
to just spit ball at an ocean go yeah
that's good and then go off do something
else but it also you know doesn't forget
him cuz he gets brought back in at a
later point particularly and this I
actually really liked because in many
ways Sydney Newman is portrayed here as
kind of a what he's a bit out of place
at the BBC because he feel
closer to American Hollywood he's not
actually he wasn't actually American he
was Canadian but he you know has that
sort of big boisterous pure you know
thing going on whereas right at the
beginning we see how that clashes with
the more you know buttoned up formal
atmosphere at the BBC but it's very easy
for characters like that to be shown to
be sleazy or uncaring and he's not he's
business minded and you get that he has
that sort of schmooze II thing and he
needs capable of just dropping sentiment
if things aren't panning out but at the
same time it also shows a value in that
because early on when they start
shooting with Hartnell and Hertel is
very uncertain about what it is that
going on he comes in and he schmooze ins
he schmooze with a hardened 'el and it
it just smooths so many things over and
it shows the value of what somebody like
that can bring to a production because
again so often we usually see behind the
scenes things it whoever is filling that
role the big schmooze II blustery kind
of person there usually a problem not a
solution so it's kind of nice to
acknowledge that yeah actually somebody
like that when deployed properly is an
asset to a production so I like that
Verity Lambert I like that a lot of
emphasis was put on yes she was the
first female director but not a ton I
didn't feel like a ton of emphasis was
put on the blockades in her way more of
just how she kept busting through them
by force of will there are some and you
do get especially early on the sense
that some of the other people aren't
respecting her but and like that should
be there it would feel weird if it
wasn't acknowledged but it doesn't dwell
on that it doesn't make that a core
thing in the story there are basically a
couple of parts when she first shows up
and basically steamrolls the guy who was
the temporary producer until the
permanent one came in which is her
because she doesn't agree with his ideas
at all and then when she needs the
TARDIS design and the designer keeps
putting her off and doing other stuff
instead she basically just sits down
I'm gonna sit here until you do it and
you can do it and then I'll be gone and
then I'll leave you alone and those are
really the only two times that that like
her not getting the respect she deserves
come up but they both encapsulate it
really really well
similarly with Wars Husain play by Sasha
Dhawan who's now the dog no sorry now
the master and that's fun and of itself
but he you know there are the
acknowledgments of the discrimination
towards him for being Indian and that
again is acknowledged in a way that
feels organic but also not lingered on
or or over emphasized since again that's
not the point of the story but it's just
really well about like let me be upfront
I think Marga he this did better work on
this script than anything else he's
written for Doctor Who I usually don't
like Mark Gatiss penned scripts for
Doctor Who some of them I'm okay with
but I I don't really love any of them
this I mean this is great and of course
that brings us to David Bradley playing
William Hartnell and aside from looking
the part very well like that that's a
big ask to to try and capture not only
what he brought to the part when he has
to recreate scenes but also to give the
conflict of what was going on with a guy
behind the scenes because there was a
lot of play with him he was an actor who
was not in a great physical condition
looked older than he actually was had
been getting have been getting
stereotyped as the same kind of role
over and over and over again was very
much a working actor needed to keep
working but felt like he was running out
of steam he didn't particularly seem to
get or get on well with kids again don't
know how accurate that is but that's how
it's portrayed here and you know is
skeptical about this thing but then once
he gets his hook into it becomes very
possessive and very protective of it and
it's there's a lot to do there there's a
lot of layers because he could have just
been the crotchety guy who keeps
forgetting his lines and is kind of a
hold up on the whole part
because on paper there were definitely
times when that's what Hartnell was but
this never loses sight of the fact that
he cares about the work he cares about
the craft and it doesn't take him that
long to care deeply about this character
and even show us how some of the things
that he's doing that annoy the casting
crew are show how good he was at what he
did there's a point later on as the the
behind-the-scenes staff is starting to
shift like they have a new director
worse Hussein has moved on and and
Verity is moving on and the lot of the
supporting cast has shifted and they're
telling him what to do for the scene
he's like no no I can't
I can't do that because I have to move
over here to use the switch to open the
door cuz he was very insistent on always
using the same switches continuously
because he knew kids would notice if he
was doing it differently each time and
again and also in terms of a production
like Doctor Who something that runs for
a long time that moment in that bit
which again not linger like this thing
really knows how to spend the exact
right amount of time on any given sort
of beat so again it's not lingered on
but it does sort of give you in a
snapshot the difference between people
shepherding an idea to build it into
something in the first place and people
brought in just to continue something
that already exists and that's not to
knock the talent of people who just come
in to keep the to keep them machine
moving but there is going to be a
difference in terms of the the level of
commitment that and the level of
investment that they have in it and
that's just a reality and it's it's well
captured in that moment and it's
interesting as it goes on because it
starts out largely as a telling of how
this show came about but by about the
halfway point it shifts to primarily
focus on Hartnell and how playing the
role and then having to leave the role
and the reasons he had to leave the role
impacted him which that sort of overall
shift can be difficult to manage but it
feels very organic here because after a
while
he was basically the only one of the
original core group of people behind the
thing who was still there Verity Lambert
was gone worse Hussain was gone the the
actors who played Susan and Ian and
Barbara were gone and it makes sense
that as he was basically the last member
of the old guard still standing to have
it shift and focus more on him
specifically as it goes along which is
where it gets a wonderful melancholy
feel because this whole thing could have
been honestly overly self celebratory it
could have but the wrong way to do this
would have been from the beginning to
treat it like Doctor Who was this
brilliant piece of media just waiting to
be birthed into the world and and every
element that came in was just about
perfect puzzle piece placed in there but
it doesn't do that because it never
loses sight of the work that had to be
done things didn't go smoothly things
didn't go perfectly so it's not overly
self congratulatory about it and that is
aided by the shift to the focus on
Hartnell because it gives it a certain
air of sadness and of melancholy because
all the other people who moved on from
the show well they moved on to do other
things
Hartnell again as portrayed here really
he didn't he didn't want to have to give
it up because he knew in his heart of
hearts he wasn't really going to get
anything after this it would be and
anything he got would be eclipsed by
this he seemed to get that this was the
last thing he was going to do that would
matter to people and I didn't remember
that this line happened in this film
before every watched it for this when he
says I don't want to go in his study to
his wife
if that hit me so much harder than when
Tennant said it in the end of time part
two now I know for some people that
moment lieutenant works like gangbusters
it has never worked for me it didn't
work when I originally aired it didn't
work when I rewatched it since it didn't
work when I revisited it you know doing
for the overdue Doctor Who reviews it's
not to say that it completely falls flat
but it never connected with me as much
as I know it wants to and it sure as
heck didn't connect with me like this
does because there is such a stronger
sense of deep sadness to what David
Bradley as William Hartnell is able to
bring to that line that he is going to
have to stop doing what is what will be
for all practical intents and purposes
the last thing he does that matters and
he knows that and he doesn't want to be
irrelevant I think part of the reason it
hits me harder here is that he's not
actually going to die at this moment
because I think part of the thing with
Tennant and his line I don't want to go
is that it's playing on basically the
the usual well I don't want to die
because that story very much went out of
its way to frame regeneration as a death
which I also don't loves so that's part
of a fashion Hawaii doesn't work for me
whereas this it's a plea to not become
irrelevant cuz Hartnell's not gonna die
but he's gonna have to keep living
knowing that his time is done and there
is a much for me at least at this point
my life a much heavier sadness to that
than just the idea of oh god I'm afraid
I'm gonna die I think the difference is
the sense of what is being lost in what
is being left behind what is being
undone
because you know the doctor tenant
cannon did regenerate and while 10
people may continue to view that it's
like he died and somebody else got to
walk away the character continues things
continue Hartnell doesn't get to
regenerate he only getting he only has
to run out his time and he wears down
and it's a lot sadder as far as I'm
concerned if there's one moment that I
do think over plays it in this it is the
bit towards the end where he sees Matt
Smith it's kind of like he has a vision
of oh it keeps going oh look how far
have we are and they like have this
little visual bonding moment and it's
not a bad moment in and of itself it
it's okay it's decently shot for a
moment with no dialogue the two actors
play it well but that is the one bit
that comes off as self-congratulation
must said self-congratulatory which
sounds wrong so self-congratulatory
there we go about the thing because it
does feel like somebody who has worked
on modern doctor who is going oh thank
God we continued to honor this legacy in
a way that feels disconnected and like
it didn't 100% work for me even at the
time it aired and it really doesn't work
now that we are so far further from Matt
Smith's time as the doctor so it's not a
complete failure of a moment but I do
think it is the one time where the
production gets self-indulgent and
self-conceited stup ick ting Doctor Who
of the 1960's but instead suddenly
become self-congratulatory of Doctor Who
of the 2010s
it's yeah it's it's an odd thing that
happens and I don't just don't really
love it but that's about the one
substantive complaint that I would make
about this and I also love
that the last bit of footage we actually
get is of Hartnell himself delivering
that iconic speech with some day I will
come back and because it's it's
brilliant and David Bradley recreates it
very well earlier in the film but I am
glad they let the actor William Hartnell
himself have that moment to close out
the film so that's an adventure in space
in time if you like Doctor Who at all or
if you just find behind-the-scenes
making-of television and movie things
interesting and even if you don't have
the much interest in Doctor Who I still
think it's worth watching it's really
good as a piece it unto itself and it's
especially good if you do have an
investment in Doctor Who as a property
so if you haven't seen it for crying out
loud watch it it's not like I spoiled
anything the plot is just what happened
in reality and what's great about it is
stuff that needs to be seen it is
performances it is pacing it is the feel
and flow of the thing and I can't rely
relay that to you in a review so go
watch it if you haven't if you have
watched it whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it all the usual stuff
like subscribe share this video around
that's greatly appreciated I have a
patreon which helps the channel grow and
helps keep this whole thing going I've
also got links to other things down in
the description but you don't have to do
any of it if you don't want to cut at
the end of the day you folks are the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]